نحو مزيد من تعزيز القدرات القتاليه تتجه
روسيا وزير الدفاع سيرجيو شويكو يتعهد
امام قيادات عسكريه روسيه كبيره ببناء
ترسانه اسلحه هجوميه احدث واقوى ورفع
كفاءه تكنولوجيا الطيران لتحسين قدرات
تفادي الدفاعات الجويه وتطوير انتاج
المسيرات تحدث وزير الدفاع الروسي عن
الحاجه لتقويه كل وسائل القتال وافرع
الجيش تقريبا مرورا لتدريب الافراد وشؤون
الامداد والاداره والاتصالات لكن اللافته
الابرز كانت تركيزه على السلاح النووي
سنواصل تطوير الثالوث النووي والحفاظ على
استعداده القتالي لان الدرع النووي كان
الضمان الرئيسي لسياده دولتنا وسلامه
اراضيها
يقصد بالثالوث النووي ثلاث وسائل اطلاق
تملكها معظم القوى النوويه وحسب تقرير
امريكي في عناصر الثالوث النووي الروسي
تشمل القوه النوويه الجويه التي تملك منها
روسيا نحو 68 قاذفه ثقيله بعيده المدى
تتجاوز سرعه الصوت والقوه النوويه البحريه
فلدي روسيا 11 غواصه نوويه مصممه لاطلاق
الصواريخ البالستيه القابله لحمل رؤوس
النوويه والتي يمكن لبعضها توليد موجات
تسونامي اشعاعيه يفوق ارتفاعها 500 متر
الى جانب القوه النوويه الصاروخيه التي
يعتقد ان لدى روسيا منها
36 صواريخ عابره للقارات يمكنها حمل نحو
الفا 12 85 راسا نوويا وبلوغ الاراضي
الامريكيه سبق للرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين اواخر العام المنصرم التعاهد برفع
الاستعداد القتالي للثالوث بلاده النووي
مع اقتراب مرور عام على بدء الحرب يتصاعد
الحديث في روسيا اذا عن رفع مستويات
الكفاءه القتاليه فهل يرد ذلك لتراجعات
وازمات ميدانيه اوضحها عدم الحسم رغم
التفاوت الحاد لموازين القوى مع اوكرانيا
التي لا يدعمها حلفائها الا وفق حسابات
دقيقه او هكذا قضوا اغلب الشهور الماضيه
مؤشرات التراجع الميداني الروسي تحدث عنها
مسؤولون امريكيون واخراريون قالوا ان
نيران المدفعيه الروسيه انخفضت عن اعلى
مستوياتها في زمن الحرب بنسبه تصل احيانا
الى 75% معتبرين ذلك دليلا على الضعف
الروسي المتزايد في ساحه المعركه لكن رغم
ذلك لا تنظر واشنطن للمعركه باعت فيها
مشرفه على الانتهاء في القريب العاجل بل
هي تغير بشكل جوهري نوعيه الاسلحه المقدمه
لاوكرانيا والتي باتت هجوميه اكثر من ذي
قبل نقل هذا عن مسؤولين امريكيين كبار
قالوا ان الاسلحه المقدمه لاوكرانيا
ستمنحها قدره اكبر بكثير وان هذا جاء بعد
التزام كياب بالقيود المفروضه على استخدام
الاسلحه الغربيه ما خفف التحفظات بشان
ارسال انظمه اكثر تطورا هو اذا سباق روسي
غربي نحو القاء المزيد من الحطب في اتوني
حرب اوكرانيا يرافقه تعزيز روسي للقدرات
القتاليه النوويه وهي مؤشرات قد تنذر بامد
ليس بالقصير قد تستغرقه الحرب